Hello Freak bitches and,
and I don't,
and you're talking to a guy.
I don't like Hillary at all.
I think she's,
I think she's more of the same.
Yes.
But I think she's a corrupt human being.
There are a lot of examples of that.
Um,
however,
I'm not as uncharitable to say that I think she's,
I don't think she's evil.
I think she has a vision for the world.
I think she wished she,
in her mind,
she believes she knows what's best for the country.
But there's a difference because I think she's willing to take big shortcuts to
gain influence and always has an a career and a short colleague.
What?
Like,
we can have big influence using political influence to get what she wants when,
when,
I mean,
if you look at the people that Clinton pardoned,
that part in scandal was the craziest thing in the world.
Did he?
Pardon?
Frank?
Rich.
We'll take a look at the list.
Frank.
Rich,
uh,
the,
the Hee Hee Hillary wanted to run for Senate in New York and he needed certain
counties and he needed a large,
I believe,
Hasidic Jewish vote vote.
And he pardoned some guy in a rabbi or somebody in there that it was such a
blur.
It's a little,
I remember the democratic somewhat,
I think it was one of the democratic pundents who said,
I don't know how you defend this.
It's just so obvious that he's trying to buy his wife votes that he's trying to
buy influence.
And that was,
that's well documented.
I don't think a lot of Democrats would disagree with that.
You know,
look it up.
Look up the uranium one.
Deal one deal.
Who through Bill Clinton's influence,
this Canadian businessman bought the Kazakh oil,
a uranium fields.
Well,
let's go one scandal at a time.
The first one,
did you find the first one?
Yeah.
Is that the guy's name?
Mark Pardons.
But look at this guy up before,
I think he was going to go down.
And it's like the,
at the time,
largest tax evasion.
Oh,
that's right.
Living in Switzerland,
prosecuting them.
Oh Wow.
Things right here in the middle.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Future.
He was a fugitive who had fled the US doing this prosecution was residing in
Switzerland.
He had $48 million in taxes and it was charged with 51 cadences.
Accounts of taxpayers was pardoned for tax evasion.
He was required to pay a $1 million fine and waive any use of the pardon as a
defense against any future civil charges that were filed against him in the
same,
in the same case.
Whoa.
Critics complain that Denise Eisenberg,
rich,
his former wife,
had made substantial donations to the Clinton library and Mrs Clinton's Senate
campaign.
What a surprise that Marc Rich,
who lives in Switzerland and you're going to give them a part,
and do you think they're connected?
It was so blatant.
It was ridiculous.
But you can keep going with the pardon's.
There are a lot of examples of that.
So to call Hillary Clinton,
not corrupt the uranium one deal.
Go ahead and look that up.
What's that?
What's Uranian?
Well.
Well,
uh,
the,
Canadian businessman bought the Kazak in Kazakhstan,
used to be a part of the Soviet Union,
a uranium fields.
Uh,
some of them,
some huge uranium fields.
I think some of the biggest in the world.
You're writing him.
What do you use to make nuclear weapons?
Oh Shit.
And Bill Clinton,
uh,
help to his,
it was his influence,
a well documented influence help this Canadian businessman by those uranium
fields.
But here's the problem.
That Canadian businessman gave $31 million to the Clinton Foundation with a
pledge for 100 million more and he gave Clinton a $500,000 check for speaking
for a speech and then 500,000 sounds.
Then when it came time for the Clinton
dinosaur bones sell for a lot of money at auctions.
It is a profitable business.
There is pressure for academics to publish papers.
Museums are in the business of producing displays that are popular and
appealing.
What the nonprofit is a business need to produce material to sell,
to stay in business.
The mainstream media loves to hype alleged dinosaur fines much just to be gained
by converting a bland non dinosaur discovery of a bone of modern origin into an
impressive dinosaur.
Find and letting artists interpretations and imaginations take the spotlight.
Okay.
Other than the basic boring,
real fine.
Um,
if,
if that's true,
uh,
the why do dinosaurs become passe?
Why does somebody like me who has been on,
I don't know,
13,
14 different television shows talking about paleontology,
geology and all that.
I have pitched dinosaur,
like live dig stuff to BBC and all of that.
I'm consulting on a couple projects right now,
unfortunately,
can't name them,
but,
uh,
dinosaurs become passe very,
very quickly because people are like,
oh,
cool,
new dinosaurs town yet big deal.
Or Oh,
well brontosauruses sources back.
Yeah,
whatever.
But the main stream media,
as you said,
is just like,
they love a dinosaurs story,
but that's bullshit.
That's absolute bullshit.
When was,
when was the last like,
dinosaur document?
Yeah,
there was,
um,
uh,
what was it called?
Autopsy of a t rex with,
uh,
my friend Tori and uh,
that,
okay.
That was a speculative science shows.
It was like what happens if we found a t rex and cut it open and do an autopsy?
That was a hit and then paleontology TV died again two years ago.
I had a net to our national geographic documentary about digging up wooly
mammoths in that it errored a night.
There was a little bit of press fucking done.
The production company that did the,
the the thing with nat geo is out of business now,
just done.
It's like,
really we're,
we're pressured and to get this money then why aren't we making fucking more?
Why Eric am I a bartender in addition to a paleontologist in addition to
somebody that's on TV,
if I'm making all this big Pharma or sorry,
big Paleo fucking money if I'm such a shill.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that why I'm a month behind on my car payment right now is why I'm trying to
scrape together rent.
Fuck.
You can aggressive.
I remember when you were like,
when I realized,
cause I don't know at the time I didn't know anything about fighting,
but then you were explaining how like their,
they have these insanely deep combos.
If this person does this,
they have all these moves like 19 moves deep that like there's incredible.
So I think she's like that.
Like she has like if he does this,
you do this.
And if he does that and this,
this,
and then that.
And then that,
And they've done it all with like a government team of psychologists who have
fully analyzed him and no out of fucking set him off.
And she did it last night.
She did it in every single fucking debate.
And it's not like she's the one who's coming up with that.
She's got a team of the smartest,
most manipulative people on planet earth who baited him in to the fucking,
uh,
elections in the first place.
You saw that email,
right?
Where they picked the three candidates that they wanted to empower,
you know,
or to like build up,
which was Trump,
what's his name?
But Cruz,
Ted fucking cruise.
Cause he's also fool because he's a fool.
And the other,
the sweet guy,
the doctor,
Rubio,
Carson,
you know,
so like they pick the three biggest fools days.
They're like,
all right,
let's pump them up.
They pump them up.
The King of the fools made his way into the fucking pres.
Somehow.
They're like,
are you fucking kidding?
We got Trump,
we got fucking Trump.
We got Trump.
Trump.
Oh,
hold on,
let me go to the Trump file.
Oh my God.
Listen to this audio of him talking about graphing fucking girls.
She's like,
okay,
great.
Let's use that and hold onto that for a while.
Yeah,
we'll do that on the day before the second day.
let's do that.
And the day before the second debate,
you know what I mean?
I think they gave it two days.
Yeah,
two days to build Zimmer,
two days to build.
And then of course they were probably working on like,
you know,
months leading up to it.
They're like,
let's find every single person that claims Donald Trump groped them or that were
groped by Donald Trump.
Anyone who's willing to claim Donald Trump broke them.
Anybody wants to get on TV?
Yeah.
How you guys failing.
And I,
but I have a feeling,
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know for sure,
but my guess would be that if you wanted to find people who said,
yeah,
Trump grabbed my pussy,
it wouldn't be that fucking hard.
It's now like you're looking for bigfoot,
pretty easy to hunt them down,
you might guess.
Right?
Yeah.
But so,
so it wasn't like a hard thing to do.
It's a bread crumb trail.
Yeah.
He very simple,
very easy.
And so it's like when you realize like that,
then you start feeling this weird compassion for him and you're like,
my God.
Even with all his like maliciousness and like weird per Venus and stuff,
ultimately he,
they,
he's like a fucking bowl that got put into a God damn ring with a matador.
He's been doing this kind of bull fighting for like 30 fucking years for better,
for worse.
And he's,
we're watching what we saw last night.
Yeah.
Okay.